do you know how sad someone's life is if  they actually decide to watch your  content and leave a negative comment you  shouldn't be sad for you you should be  sad for them deploy compassion to those  who [ __ ] on you i think the reason i'm  winning is when somebody says you're an  idiot you're a scam you're full of [ __ ]  you suck you're ugly [ __ ] you my brain  immediately goes to like man for  somebody to take time out of their day  to come to my profile to try to tear me  down because they're hurting so much  inside i only have love for them i'm  aware that we're in a societal place  right now where the way we respond to  people's hate is with hate back to them  but i just don't have that gear when i  get [ __ ] on i deploy love through the  form of compassion if you're able to do  that you won't hear them i love  compassion i think it's a [ __ ] hard  skill